haha haha haha hello everybody it's it's it's 2006 I just
found this really cool game called Toho project and I'd like
to play it today
A game apparently came out a couple years ago.
And...
It seems really cool and a little bit tough.
But I think we can do it.
Natsukashi!
Hi, everybody.
Hello,
everybody.
Hello, kitten.
Wait, not you.
You one up here?
Yeah?
Come on up.
You one up?
I'm not calling you guys kitten.
Come here.
Actually, I probably...
Well, no, he eats in a couple hours.
Meow.
Watching in 240p for my immersion.
Well, actually, I set this up, and then I was like...
I was like, wait a second.
Because I was like, oh, vertical stream on Toho.
It looks really dukey right now, but in the game it looks
great.
But...
Then I was like, wait, they wouldn't have vertical streams
back then.
So...
My immersion is broken.
Because I wouldn't have had...
But don't think about it.
Don't think about it.
Hold on.
You guys, my cat.
I have a cat now.
You guys, I have a cat now.
I have a cat.
Oh my gosh.
Let me nightmare.
Oh, did you hear that?
That was him hitting his head.
Hey baby, come here.
Come in here.
Come into my lap.
Come here.
I don't know if I can play like this, but it's okay.
Hi.
Here, I'll see if I can, you guys can hear him.
Come here.
Stop.
Stop that.
Come here.
Guys, I would like to introduce you to my new cat.
Konbaku, everybody.
Can you hear him?
Oh no, no, no, I have to hold your butt.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, hold on.
Put your butt there.
Can you hear him?
I don't do, oh my god, oh, oh, don't lick me, don't lick me.
No, stop it, stop that, that's gross.
You guys, I would like to introduce you to Johnny.
Johnny Akibo.
Hello, baby boy.
He's my little baby boy.
And he is not a shitter, luckily.
But he, here I'll turn the music back on.
he um is a dopey guy he's very silly he's very dopey yeah
aren't you so dopey and stupid and he's got some gnarly
teeth and because of that he drools howdy John my cat licks
my face all the time yeah he like kind of lunges he does the
whole like in your face just like in Metal Gear there's even
a John There you go.
Are you leaving?
Goodbye!
Yes, I'm speaking about my cat.
That's so cute and gross.
He's really stinky.
He's really silly.
He licks definitely an eyeball.
Don't say that!
Are you...
Are you complaining over there?
He's very...
He's very vocal.
Johnny is the perfect name.
Sorry for even suggesting other names.
Babycore, thank you for the podcast.
Nimi, thank you so much for the raid earlier.
Sorry, my cat was just getting up into my lap.
Where does you...
Where does you raided?
But he's a big complainer.
He's a big meower, so you might hear him sometimes.
But he's been so cute.
He's been so good.
He slept with me all last night.
Um...
Uh...
Okay.
Yeah, he's... he's a...
He's a... he's so cute.
I'll take some pictures eventually, but...
Not quite yet.
Wait a minute.
I'm getting him...
You know, it's like...
It's like showing off a baby.
Happy 9-day, my beloved 1.0 mission raid...
Yo such a no thank you!
Oh my gosh, did you see at the post about...
about how how how patchouli does not actually have stripes
but i prefer the stripes actually he's a meower or one might
say a chatter definitely a daibu congrats on the new cat
johnny sounds so cute all this cat talk is making me miss my
cat but i'm going home for the weekend i'll be seeing him
soon how a good time love your 2002 model thank you it's
time for toho i thought also if i'm playing toho i I should
wear my Yomu from Timu.
My Yomu from Timu look, you know.
So it's my old model, my old look.
Happy Churno day, happy Baka day, everybody.
Baka, Baka.
Why do our hands look like that?
Why?
Why would you say that?
Ache has stripes and soku, funnily enough.
Well, they kind of change outfits, so it makes sense, but...
1.0 Minto instills cuteness aggression.
Cat tree puns, thank you!
VTubers existed in the 90s?
We're in the 90s now?
When did you... did you guys ever play Toho?
I think I played Toho the first time.
uh 2009 10 definitely a long time ago but i was not like on
the you know the uh the the first you know hits of it like i
did i didn't play when it first came out or anything super
rare retro Minto 1.0, can I get a happy birthday?
Huey, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Sorry when Toho 7.5 released.
Wait, which one was that?
Oh gosh, the numbers.
6 was subterranean animism, right?
And so 7 would be UFO, and then 7.5 would be one of the Oh
gosh.
Wait, 11?
Oh wait, this is 6!
Oh my gosh!
I'm so off.
My brain!
Mindo, this is 6.
Okay, wait.
Don't listen to me.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
This is 6.
That's right.
Oh my gosh.
Well, it's like the first of PC.
So...
7 was Perfect Cherry Blossom.
Which it would be even better if I was playing Perfect
Cherry Blossom with this look.
Mm-mm.
Toho was my big obsession before VTubers.
I would say me too.
Well, I was Toho.
Then Idols.
Inmaterial of missing power.
Yes.
Why are hands like that?
Stop asking!
PCB was where I started.
Yeah, the fighting game.
I didn't really play the fighting games, I'll be honest.
Because I was never a fighting game person.
The only, like, 0.5 game I played was the one with IA, the
photo game.
Oh, gosh.
It's been so long since Toho.
Welcome back, 1.0, Minato!
Shoot the bullet!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Shoot the bullet, shoot the bullet.
Yes, yes, yes.
we're playing vertical today it looks kind of stinky right
now but we are vertical we are vertical for toho once i
start playing it'll look proper did you play imperishable
night i played consistently everything up to ufo and then
afterwards like it kind of got you know after life happened
it was harder for me to play a lot of things and also it was
my birthday yesterday i couldn't get a belated happy
birthday uncle spooky happy birthday happy birthday i know
toho through the music i mean toho has great music i'm lucky
to play toho games at a con and the guy who brought them in
told me i looked like kind of like the guy who who'd know
toho what does that mean
toho 17 is 100 worth it i've it's been it's been tougher for
me to The trumpets are going off.
It has been harder for me to keep up with newer releases as
well.
I know there was just a new one, wasn't there?
And then...
I remember the one girl that it looks like a hot topic
girly.
I think she's a couple years old now, though.
Who's your favorite Toho girly?
Mine is Suika.
I love Vermilia.
I love Kogasa.
Oh, I love...
Oh, I love so many.
I love Aya.
I love...
I love a lot.
I remember when he debuted with this model, I was so blown
away by how professional it looked.
Time does fly, right?
Now I'm a thing of the past.
VTubers like, you got me bugged at anime.
I haven't watched anime since my teens until gotten to
VTubers.
Oh my gosh, that's crazy.
I was addicted to Toho and when I was young.
Side note, Johnny can lick me and Alice and Ghost Gardener
are the cutest.
Alice is pretty cute.
It's cool to see Mantis, Minto.
There's a lot.
Oh, a lay wormy.
Thank you.
Yeah, vertical jump scare.
vertical jump scare oh I love Chen and run I love Chen Chen
I just woke up from the craziest dream felt like six years
ago anyway looking forward to Phoenix right this weekend
yeah I'm voicing all of Phoenix right I gotta finish the
games I gotta finish though the the there's only three games
out so far I hope they make more.
Check out the Toho 20 girls.
Mitsigami and Jushin girl is cute.
I'm not.
I'll be honest.
I love Nue from UFO.
But my favorite theme, one of my favorite themes is
Biakuren's theme from UFO.
I love basically the whole soundtrack of Mountain of Faith.
So Yeah, classic model reminds me of my first dreams
watching your Ace Attorney play through.
No way, happy 9-9 my birthday was also yesterday.
I think this coupon for minty cheese still works.
Happy birthday!
My hands are adorable.
Well, they're still like this.
They're just usually covered under my sleeve.
So, you know, I guess since you can't see them so often,
people aren't making fun of them so often, I suppose.
Centennial Festival for Magical Girls.
I'm the worst at remembering names, though, of the songs and
everything.
Because the names are, like, Centennial Festival for Magical
Girls.
And I'm like, that's, that's like a light novel title.
I just finished MGS4 this week, and you went ahead and named
your cat Johnny Sasaki.
No, it's Johnny Akiba, actually.
Yeah, we gotta get him a Meryl.
They're all word salad.
Mm-hmm.
But you're not wrong.
Dei Sen is my favorite.
Udonge.
I always like talking.
I mean, it's been a long time since I've been into Toho so
much, but there's something so...
I mean, I was really...
I was...
You know, Toho consumed my afterlife at some point in time.
So I was so, you know...
to play and watch people play and talk about it with my
friends and cosplay and everything so it just feels very
very very like nostalgic and I can't believe like playing
this again on steam of all things it's crazy ignore my name
by the way meep thank you so much for the 20k so
Minto right now is like how the adult who tries out their
old high school uniform does the old skin still fit?
It still fits and it still fits perfectly.
What are you talking about?
What are we talking about?
Happy Chirno Day to his strongest ghost maid.
Do you guys say Chirno or do you say Chirno?
Do you say Chirno or do you say Chirno like the weeb that
you are?
Cirno Koishi and Oku are my number one babes.
Subterranean Animism was my first game.
It's hard.
Fell in love with Toho back in 2018 because of it.
Wow, that's pretty late.
Awesome.
I say Cerno.
Chirno, so Chirno.
Chirno.
I say it like, because it's like chill, you know?
She's an ice fairy.
Chirno.
So I say Chirno.
I say Chirno.
I say chill no.
Yeah, I say Marukyu, Circle 9.
I say Chiro.
Just call her Baka.
Yeah.
She's a big old Baka Baka.
I think it's so funny that...
You know, that's where...
The kids are losing the text, the ancient texts.
Nobody uses Marukyu anymore for idiots.
And then...
Nobody uses a Maru-Kyo anymore!
I say, sir, no, because there's not an H in it.
I guess it depends on how...
Well, I mean, like, if you localize it.
C-H-I-R-N-O.
Because it is Chiruno.
So it could be.
You know?
Depends on the localization.
Maru-Kyo, Maru-Kyo, Maru-Kyo, Maru-Kyo, Maru-Kyo.
Suika is so cute though.
What's the girl?
Yugi?
Suika and Yugi.
I love Suika though.
Suika is very, very cute.
Yeah.
There's so many...
Toho is just like so one of a kind, you know?
Hmm.
How do you pronounce...
Tei, tei, tei, tei, tei.
Tei, tei.
Tei, tei, tei.
I cannot help but say, tei, tei, tei, tei,
Is this game a remake or a new iteration?
It is a remake.
It is a remake of the original embodiment of Scarlet Devil.
Toho 6, which I completely forgot earlier.
I don't have no idea what comic you're talking about.
At least we can all agree.
Riggle Nightbug sucks!
Why would you say that?
I love Riggle.
Kind of reminds me of Berrybug.
Actually, I feel like, though, out of character designs,
maybe...
EOSD has my favorite.
I think...
Maybe out of...
Which is kind of crazy because it's like the first PC game,
but...
Or the first PC Toho game, you know?
But out of like so many Toho games, I love the character
designs in this one.
So I'm very, very excited.
Very, very excited.
Mountain of Faith also has banger designs.
It's very true.
Very true.
Yeah.
Vicky is Sekibanky.
Who is Phoebe?
Any of the...
Like, for some reason, my brain wants to say, like, Lily
White.
You know?
Yuka's obviously my favorite, but I would honestly say Remi
is my second favorite.
Remi is so cute!
So cute!
Phoebe is Dayose.
Yes, Phoebe is Dayose.
That's true, that's true, that's true.
Are you Yomu's sister?
I'm Team U-Yomu.
Love the Autumn sisters too.
What was it?
Aki and...
I can't remember.
Shizuka!
I want to be kicked by Mei Ling.
I want to say also...
It's been a very long time since I've played this game.
And I was never good at the Damaku games.
I just played them for music.
Hina!
I love Hina theme.
I just play them for music and vibes and we can all enjoy
cute girls.
Shaman Maru!
So many good memes came out of...
Out of Toho.
Gosh.
I suck at these games really bad.
That's okay.
I mean, you can only get better by playing them.
And if you don't play them, you're not gonna be good.
Mountain of Faith mentions Suako, my wife.
Kero, Kero, Kero, Kero.
Come on, thank you so much for that talk!
You're good!
Been sitting on the name Yu-Yu-Yu-Ko-Sai-Geoji for 16 years!
because of random pics of art that depicted that Twitter
account but never registered I what wait so you have the
Yu-Yu-Ko Twitter account that's crazy
and for a good time since EOSD is one of the hardest since
it didn't have quality of life yet I wonder though what they
added and if they changed much in this because basically for
this release obviously I'm not sponsored or anything but um
this is the new classic version and then there is the
classic version that you can all that also it's like a
bundle that you get for this so as long as I can see yeah
you can see the hitbox as long as I can see my hitbox so I
can properly graze I think we'll be okay maybe
If this is your first exposure to Toho, don't...
I think a lot of people probably think that Toho is very...
Oh, what's the word?
Intimidating?
Not just because the games are pretty tough, but also
because...
You're like, oh my gosh.
It has been around for so many years!
How am I ever going to keep up?
How am I ever going to catch up?
but honestly so much of it is like fan interpretations of
characters and of things there's really the story in these
games and the bullet hell games is quite minimal um it's
quite it's quite minimal like kind of people will just read
the little bit of dialogue that is in these games and kind
of interpret their characters from there yeah a lot of the
story is fan made yeah so yeah so it's really just kind of
like you can start wherever which is kind of nice but the
basic of the or the basis of most of these stories is Reimu
you see here Hakurei Reimu nothing wrong with picking
starting in easy mode I'll start I'll aren't normal but uh
easy mode but yeah raymu is a shrine maiden and uh something
is going on in gen sokyo the weather is off in gen sokyo and
raymu must go investigate why hi x thank you so much for
that 500 oh my god 50 gift oh my gosh that'd be insane thank
you thank you thank you so much thank you thank you the
vibes are off yeah which to who would you hug all of them
next question
what is gen sokyo gen sokyo is the land that they live in is
it's old japan ye old japan but it is like ye old mythical
japan called gen sokyo where there is only women in one that
lives or actually there might be is there more than one guy
now have more men been bred birthed not bred oops wait
the village exists what there's like a couple okay we got a
couple guys now
It's actually like a 50-50 split, but they just never show
any guys.
No, there's just no men.
It's like strike witches.
Men and pants don't exist.
That's my, that's my fanon.
That's my Accept all What's his name?
Renosuke I guess he's fine maybe Just like in Neptunia
Renosuke exists kind of
Like Love Live Oh no We're only the dads are allowed to
exist Happy Terno Day You're slowly becoming my fave What do
you play?
I always play Marisa Oh you know what?
Thank you so much for the Super Chat I don't know We can
master spark with Marisha today.
Babe Toho Keg, Jermaine's Momiji.
I love Ramelea.
I'm basic.
But I also really love Kogasa and Patchouli.
Yeah.
Wait, maybe you should practice start, right?
It's been a minute.
Master spark.
The infamous.
Kyo no minnawa.
What do I gotta do to have you play Neptunia?
I don't know.
Maybe someday.
All right.
Wait, shoot.
How do you bomb again?
No, I don't need to know how to bomb.
I don't need to know how to bomb.
Look at this.
Oh my gosh.
Gosh, you can see the hitbox crazy.
No, I'm letting them.
I'm letting these little fairies get away.
Give me, give me, give me, give me.
And then, Zoon redid the music for like this remake.
So it's pretty cool.
It's pretty cool.
No, please, please, please, please.
Please!
Bonus.
I avoided all the points.
Oops.
Bye bye.
Oh my gosh, it's been so...
The trumpets!
The zoom pits.
The zoom pits are zoom pitting.
For sure.
We don't need to...
Oh, I forgot.
We don't need to know how to bomb everybody.
The tumpets.
This kind of feeling.
How to put it.
No, I heard she'd probably say, It sure feels great out.
Who could that be?
I hate the night, though.
There's only weirdos out at this hour.
And you can really hear the influence on Toby Toho Project.
Right!
Oh, Rubia!
Gourou, Gourou, Gourou, Gourou.
Nobody's talking about you.
Yes, that makes it.
Like, the art is so cute!
Oh my gosh.
Why are you holding your arms out like that?
Doesn't it give you the image of the saint was crucified?
Oh my god, the art is so cute.
It looks more like humanity just invented addition.
What does that mean?
Because she's a plus?
Oh shoot!
Oh gosh!
It's begun.
Don't worry about it.
Am I getting her?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I gotta lock in.
Holy cow.
Oh, shoot.
I gotta... Hold on.
Wait, I gotta turn off my fan.
It's like blowing in my eyes.
I can't look.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
It's over.
I'm dying on Rumiya.
Stage one.
It's okay.
This is practice, isn't it?
Toho is all...
It's so...
Like, little tiny movements and locking in.
I think my eyes are...
too old for this game no my oh she is washed no
graze graze graze graze graze oh shoot i didn't even see it
it's so over my oh she is old i'm excited this remake even
exists i always wish the reward toho's dreams and the
classic model is super nostalgic thanks for the stream thank
you wait i missed a birthday mechanical happy Yay!
This version, Minto means I'm only turning 23 today.
Happy 23rd birthday!
Going cross-eyed grandma.
Okay, hold on.
We're in warm-up.
Wait, I wish though...
I wish though I could, uh...
Go like, well, maybe I don't even...
Maybe I don't need to practice.
I'm already too good at the game.
I died on purpose so that we could just end the practice
round, you know, guys?
And if you're about to die, you can...
You can, uh...
You know...
What's the word?
You can bomb out of it.
But nobody does that.
It's a myth.
I would never tell you to do that.
And I wouldn't do it myself, ever.
You know?
I would never tell you to do that.
Just don't think about my playing and enjoy the music, guys.
Thank you guys for the super chats.
I almost want to turn them off because I would suggest not
super chatting.
I'm not going to see it.
I'm just going to tell you now.
I won't be able to see your super chats.
I don't feel so bad.
We can get higher score here.
Come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come
here, come here, go, go, go, go, go.
Nice.
Actually, I don't even remember how to bomb, actually,
though.
Whoa, let's go.
Big bonus.
Nice.
And not only with this, when you focus, know you can see
your hitbox but then you can also like hone your attack to
to them you know so no stop sending stop sending oh yeah i
wonder do not humans not know how to do math oh yeah
exercise oh wait there's achievements i i got an achievement
for that.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
That's what the practice is.
Oh, shoot.
Well, let's go do it for real, then.
Start game!
Yoink.
Come back.
Come back, please.
Let me let me eat your delicious points.
And if you're like, dang, really not doing the strategy or
whatever stuff i never learned them so don't give me heck
for it okay
don't give me heck for it
no no no please please please please die die die die die die
die die oh die die die die
oh oops i missed all of those didn't i i was trying to go up
to grab them you can go like to a of the screen like that
and you can grab the uh i talk like i'm a freaking
professional but i don't know i'm really only saying it for
the people that have never ever played never ever toho'd
before in their lives or after lives whatever you prefer you
know like that see you'll collect everything on the screen
we
appreciate it thank you and you can press uh control to skip
text And since we, uh, like, it goes really fast.
Ooh, that was close.
Watch my graze.
My eyes are, like, not conditioned to...
Oh, shoot.
See?
My eyes are not conditioned to, like, playing this game
anymore, though.
It's just crazy.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I messed up.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, gosh, I'm such an idiot.
Don't worry about me.
Don't worry.
Oh, shoot.
Hmm.
Oh, please.
Take her out.
Yeah.
Remember to bomb.
I don't...
Is it X?
What is a bomb?
I don't want to test it.
I'll test it.
If I'll test it, uh...
When I feel like I need to.
Get out of my face.
is bomb on keyboard I was seeing people playing this with
like a mouse earlier I'm like oh my gosh like Japanese
players are like playing it with a mouse like they're kind
of like going on the screen because of it you know so funny
Daichan so you'll have you know Rumiya was like a stage 1
boss and also mid boss but you'll have sometimes on some
characters that are quite literally only mid bosses and so
it's very funny when like people get attached to these
characters because it's like come on come on come on come on
I don't think I'm gonna get her unfortunately I'm pretty I'm
being pretty literal with my yeah I didn't get her dang it
it's pretty funny when you have people like making
characters and like, uh, personalities and stuff for these,
like, literal nobodies.
But to us, they're not nobodies.
Oh, I totally missed that.
To us, they're not nobodies.
Could have sworn the island was around here somewhere.
Has it been moving around?
You guys might recognize somebody coming up.
Not to mention.
Wasn't it supposed to be summer?
Why is it so cold?
You'll I've never set footed on island again.
Oh, on land again.
So you're the, it sounds so good.
Better than hot, don't you think?
Oh my gosh, she looks so cute.
Gosh, this is peak.
Bet you're used to a cold reception.
I feel like that means something else.
Don't give yourself a headache.
Ouch!
I forgot to bomb.
Oh,
grace.
Oh, I tried to bomb.
No, why?
I pressed X.
Why didn't it work?
Thank you for that, Kasupa.
Oh, shh.
Oh, oops.
It's fine.
I turn it down.
Who was...
thinking of
oh wow I forgot this spell card oh my gosh
I'm lazy
And now it's such pretty colors, right?
Oh, I've missed all of that.
That's fine, though.
Can I get her?
Oh, shoot!
I went right into it!
Ah!
We're fine.
They're also...
They give you, like, a...
Whoa!
What's it called?
Um...
They have, like, an infinite lives thing now, on this.
Vibing to the music can be dangerous.
I'd hurry and find a manor that'll serve me tea or
something.
Oh my god, yeah, don't look at it.
Whoa, whoa, wait!
Oh my gosh, I just realized the...
Maybe I shouldn't have done...
Um...
Oh, my bad, sorry, I was looking at something else.
Uh...
Vertical.
Hold on.
I'm wondering if I should, if I made a mistake.
Not me dying in a stage, just in a normal stage.
Maybe I shouldn't have done vertical stream.
Yay!
Hog melee!
The guard of...
of uh the manor oh my gosh it sounds so good okay lock it in
am i even hitting her I don't think I am that's okay oh
thanks for this over time oh nice oh oh My name is Hongo Mei
Ling.
Screw you.
My name is Hongo Meiwa Hongo Mei Ling.
Check out my grays.
Leave me alone.
Stinking fairies.
Wow, beautiful.
Sick, nasty grays.
Thanks for that, just now.
She looks so dopey.
Long time, no see.
Wait, since...
Wait, did we know each other?
Since just a moment ago?
Marisha is like a little...
She's a little troll.
Whatever, you're in my way.
You're a guard around here, right?
It's a guard's job to get in the way.
So you are a guard, then.
Oh my gosh, for a second.
a little thing on her hat that looked like Kiara's little
guy.
Normal person, now face of my judgment.
How on earth were you raised?
You guys ever get into the flow state?
Obviously I was not, but you know what I mean?
Oh my gosh.
It's like when you play a oh my god, oh my god.
A rhythm game.
And you get into the flow state.
I need to achieve it.
I need to achieve low state status.
Oh, why?
Oh, I just brought that in my side.
Oh.
Nice!
How many?
Oh, I have three bombs.
Good to know.
Screw it.
Gimme, gimme, gimme!
I don't remember the spell cards enough anyway to remember
which ones I hated the most.
you know oh my god I hate ones like these though oh gosh it
feels like they're every like that they're evil they're evil
they're full evil how the hell am I supposed to read this I
can't read this I can't read either just as I thought it
isn't my style to fight oh this is 100% a lie oh she's all
beat up dang her clothes are literally literally falling
off.
Oh, I got sticky keyed.
No, no, no.
Turn off sticky key.
Wait, turn off.
No.
Wait, do you want to turn on?
Turn off sticky key.
Thank you.
Is a Koakuma next?
Oh my gosh, go away.
Koakuma?
Nanpatually?
I can't remember.
This is what you're not Really?
Well, not that you're not supposed to, but you can get
yourself in a real bind if you, like, start going up the
walls.
You know what I mean?
Oh my god.
Oh, screw it.
I'm bombing on a stage.
Oh, yeah.
Welcome mid-boss, then patchy.
Okay, that's what I thought.
Yeah.
I love Kuakumat too.
She's so cute.
So cute.
Wait.
I have to...
Oh my gosh, it's so retro.
It won't let me type it in.
Minto.
Where is it?
Where's T?
Oh.
It's okay.
Replay cannot be saved because a continue was used.
Okay, well, actually that's fine.
Smug churno judges you.
Thank you for the super chat.
You were on the T and went to plus.
Oh, wait, really?
Wait.
Raimu attempt?
Yeah, let's try Raimu instead.
Raimu looks so no nonsense.
Serious girl.
How?
Homeing amulet, baby.
That would suck to play this color blind, I think.
I think it would be really bad.
playing this colorblind.
Oh, shoot.
I missed a thing.
I think I used to always play Rainbow.
So playing her just feels right.
Ow.
She's the protagonist after all.
I also am just a Rainbow enjoyer.
I like her design more.
Sorry, everybody.
Sure feels great, though.
There aren't many spirits about during the day, so I'm
trying my luck at night.
Where am I supposed to go?
It's dark.
Still.
It's so romantic out behind the shrine at night.
Carefree.
You said it.
All the monsters, too.
Got to love those.
Wait.
Who are you?
Didn't we just see each other?
Wait, are you night blind?
The thing about humans is that we can't see very well in the
dark.
Oh, I feel like I've seen ones who are only active at night.
Carefree.
If you want to grab those ones for dinner, then go ahead.
Is that so?
So, you know, you're in my way.
Are you the sort of human I can eat?
Have you ever heard the saying, good medicines taste better?
Oops.
Happy Chernobyl Day.
I can't believe they were...
I mean, I feel like they released it today on purpose,
right?
They had to have.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm not paying attention.
My bad.
They had to have.
Get my graze.
Get my score up, baby.
I'm actually too baby for grazing.
It's scary.
Oh, whoops.
I don't remember what our bomb is.
I don't remember anything.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, it is 9-10 and...
Wait.
I guess it is.
Something about taking...
Something taking something.
Oh, stop.
No, do you want to turn on sticky keys?
No, no, please.
Stop asking me about sticky keys.
I'm just trying to make it look funny.
I know the sprites look so good.
No, everything looks so good.
I'm so...
I watched the direct after I woke up this morning.
And...
I was thinking, it's kind of relevant to this, is like, I
saw the trailer for the new Persona 4 remake, and I was
like, you know, I only played a little bit of Persona 4, but
I thought the remake looked really good.
It, like, looked like how I remembered it looking like,
despite being all brand new, like, you know what I mean?
Like in my head, I was like, oh yeah, this is the same as
before.
But...
I know!
Yo-Kai Watch, you guys!
I screamed!
I was like, yo-Kai Watch!
But, uh...
Because I've played a good handful of the Yo-Kai Watch
games.
I have many hours in that series.
But, um...
I didn't get it.
Um...
Sorry, I'm just like talking while trying to pay attention
while also Trying to yop at you guys That's how the Persona
4 thing is how I feel about this game Like this looks how I
remember it, you know From before
Vintage Monkey
Yeah, it's hard to play and yeah That's okay.
Um...
But like...
I know this is new, but like back then this is how it looked
to me.
You know what I mean?
Look at this stupid head.
Shootable opponent?
Now that is a surprise.
Quit teasing me!
I'll keep you frozen until I forget you're even there.
Thank you for the super die!
Sorry I can't read them.
I suggest just not sending them at all.
Oh my gosh!
paternal
oh that was so close that was so close
I don't even know who I'm trying to get to today wait hold
on I gotta go check on my kit
I feel like At least try Perpetually Yeah, yeah, yeah, of
course Sakuya, Lin Sakuya Flan Okay, yeah We'll get the flan
Uh I feel like a worried mom Being like I have to stop every
two seconds For my cat For my child To check on them
Oh Oh Oh
My throat is bothering me so much today.
And I've been like muting to...
Oh shoot!
Oh ow!
I'm such an idiot.
I've been muting to make it not so you can't hear it but
like me clearing my throat.
But I can't do that with this game.
I have to stop.
This one is like, when I think of Toho, I think of the song,
you know?
Apusir forever.
Like, this song just sounds like Gensokyo to me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, it was a dummy though.
The music just sounds so good, though.
There she is.
make it at least i didn't make it to koakuma did i no i
don't think so oh i won't make it at this rate holy cow oh
my gosh
oh no whoops i know whoopsie poopsie
yoink thank you wham bam thank you ma'am we take those No,
we take those for sure.
Wow, wow, wow.
Oh my god.
Oh, shh.
I could not see that all.
Oh, ouch.
Quit following me.
Thanks for leading the way.
You know you can follow me all you want, but there's nothing
over you.
You wouldn't run away to the middle of nowhere, would you?
Well, when you need to run, you just just run.
Who are you, anyway?
Uh, just a normal person.
Didn't you attack me just now?
That was a perfectly normal attack.
Besides, you attacked first.
Mailing does look so silly.
You're the one who's not normal.
I'm a perfectly normal person who works as a shrine maiden.
That's good to hear.
If I remember correctly, they say that shrine maidens are
the kind of human it's okay to eat.
Who is saying this?
Stop spraying!
Spreading that around!
Who is saying this?
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh my gosh, my eyes really are just not conditioned to
watching these anymore.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Screw it.
I was running out of time anyway.
Oh god, oh golly golly.
Screw it.
Get me out of this.
I'm gonna die.
I'm already dead and I'm gonna...
Screw it.
Use my bombs.
Nah.
Alright, you can show me the way.
I'm so sorry, mistress!
Alright.
Kwakuma Paturi.
Knowledge.
Wow-wee!
Oh my goodness.
I'm made for Toa Horde mode.
Why can't I just be a cute girl?
Appreciator!
Oh my gosh.
Let me just look at the cute girls.
Do nothing else.
Orbs.
Oh my god!
I ran right into it.
Oh there it is.
There's my plus sign.
Wait, how do I get rid of it?
How do I get rid of it?
The book mobs.
What kind of library is this?
Min plus um.
Let's see, hold on.
Maybe I don't...
I don't...
I remember not liking...
Oh, that...
This one.
The dream amulet.
So we'll go with spirit amulet.
Stage three practice.
Oh, wait.
I thought we would...
Hold on.
Never mind.
Oh my god, the sounds are so...
Nistolic.
Rimo B?
Rimo B is my way to go?
Really?
Well, it's been so long since I've played.
It doesn't hurt to retry, I think, right?
It's not like I have a real play style anymore anyway, so...
Why not, right?
Why not?
Oh, I'm so slow.
Isn't Marisa a little faster?
Oh!
Sorry, my finger slipped.
My finger slipped.
Oh my gosh.
Just got the game and I'm so rusty.
Yes.
Like, there's a lot of things that I would say your muscle
memory can like, I mean, I didn't play so much Toho.
Like, obviously I was involved in the fandom, but, like, as
for the games, I just, you know.
A little bit.
But I feel like these types of games, you...
You seriously, like, will lose it, you know?
Like, it's not, like, riding a bike where you could be like,
Oh, I just picked it back up!
You know?
Like, it's...
It's...
Death out here.
I'm not gonna make this one for sure.
I gotta stop reading chat.
I wanna talk with you guys, but this game makes it
impossible.
How is the volume anyway?
But also Toho is a game that makes me want to be like, I
want to get good at Toho.
It's good?
Okay, awesome.
Romeo.
She's spinning.
Spinning girl.
Wow, wow.
Oh, I don't want to run right into it!
Oh, screw it all.
Screw it all.
Like the instrumentation of this new version of Rumia.
That sounds so good.
Guys!
I want to play easy mode.
Whoever said screw easy mode?
They... I don't know.
We're a hater.
KEMOI!
I ran right into the stinking fairy.
Get out of my way, fairy.
Oh, dang.
I was so bad.
Maybe I should just do unlimited lives and see how far we
can get.
Dayose.
What kind of fairy is Dayose again?
I do not remember.
fairies she's big a big fairy oh then that wouldn't be
Phoebe
Phoebe's one centimeter taller than me oh my gosh thank you
so much for that Kasupa thank you
I still think Lily why wait what are the names of the what's
the like the little the trio that plays the instruments or
whatever I mean there's three of them.
Or four of them?
I can't remember.
The Prism Rivers.
Cherno looks huge in this sprite.
Am I crazy?
Oh my gosh.
No.
Hold on.
Guys, I want to see.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Give me five lives.
Wait.
Oh wait.
You can change it.
Ooh, classic.
Whoa.
Turned to always look as big as a boss.
Ooh, let's listen to the classic music.
And do five lives.
Oh, I missed.
I missed a pile of...
Just eating things right now.
Oh,
this sounds...
This sounds like it, huh?
Oh, yeah, guys.
Do we remember?
A 21st night of September.
Romeo, let me kill you, please.
Romeo, please take it, please.
Let me get the bonus, please.
Please, please.
Why are you so all over the place?
She's so wiggly.
Oh
my god!
Wow!
It's been a million years since I've listened to this!
Oh my god!
it's so good nice
too where's my infinite lives game you promised oh my god
don't let me die on room yet it's so embarrassing
oh it's even though hi play challenge mode you think I'm
gonna beat challenge oh wait does challenge mode have the
infinite lives you have to select infinite lives mode there
was none i saw i saw
i'm not gonna lie this stage looks terrible with the water
like as bright as it is i don't remember it being this
bright before like this is the the bright blue water with
the green neon green this looks so terrible
Terrible.
Tag confirmed.
At least I could see colors.
Yeah, how about you?
Huh?
You probably didn't even know this was...
You probably didn't even know it was blue.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Dayose, die.
Do the part of your damn.
I command you.
Where are you?
No, no, no.
I almost got you!
Yeah!
Bonus!
Oh, grayscale is all I need.
Oh, dang it.
I could have gotten that, but I was a coward.
What?
I'm already starting to get hungry.
I feel like I just ate.
Oh wait, I didn't have a very big lunch.
That's probably why.
Don't book.
You guys are distracting me!
Oh my gosh, the streamer is streaming and also playing a
game.
Oh my god, oh shoot, it's over, it's over.
It's so over.
The streamer is not paying attention!
Oh, why would I bomb?
Ah!
Streamer, don't read this.
Oh gosh.
I need to actually, oh my god, I actually need to pay
attention.
I might have to eat so I can focus somewhere else I won't
feel like that.
to properly play the game.
Let's chat while I eat and regain my strength.
I don't think it was the run either.
Losing on Cherno, how embarrassing.
Cherno,
happy birthday!
No.
Cherno is the strongest.
Let her have a win on her birthday or on her day.
Play to the end with unlimited lives.
Oh, I see it.
Me too cute.
I don't think I'll ever be able to untrain myself from
saying Ciorno instead of Ciorno.
I think that's why.
I mean, there's no official.
Do your arms get tired holding them up like that?
Um, not really, but, you know, it does make playing this
game.
difficult I'm playing with a handicap guys look at my arms
look at this how can a ghost with these arms play like this
chill no let's do infinite live mode okay at 8 so I already
feel a bit better just gotta get some grub in the tongue no
yeah for those who Played original.
And have played this.
Which do you like better?
Nothing wrong with Infinite Live mode.
I just want to listen to...
Wait!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I forgot to switch the music back over.
I wanted to hear the new music.
Sorry.
and we do the infinite lives so we can get as far as
possible you know yeah there we go
i played the og poorly this looks great i mean it does look
great it's very i believe you know it's again it's been a
million years since i was playing the original but it looks
accurate without being like you know some of the newer games
have like super like a bunch of stuff and This doesn't
really have that, which is pretty nice.
Feels like a remaster.
I mean, well, it is.
Didn't...
Wasn't it like, Zune said that he had lost, like, the files
for this or something?
So, a remake was, like, something that people had hoped but
didn't think they would ever have.
Never watched, but realizing...
Watching, never played, but watching this made me realize
that one of my favorite guns had INSPO.
I mean, Danmaku games, like the bullet hell games
themselves, obviously aren't a new genre even when Toho
happened, but...
You know, a lot of games, more games maybe than you realize,
were influenced by Toho.
it was it was actually just that influential like toho is
that game
she's that girl you know
so many anime as well yeah
which is it's it's such a one of a kind thing like it feels
like we'll never have a phenomenon like toho ever again like
it's you know influence with gaming and i mean like just
because it's like such a dogen project like it's a one guy
made this you know like and then it just transformed into
this huge everything
toho molded early internet culture it did a lot it really
you know it's just so fun by the power of cute girls and
baller music and you know You might see these sprites and
think like the art looks silly.
It looked even sillier before.
And people still liked it so much, you know?
People still liked it so much.
They were like...
It has soul.
I still...
But I'm a believer in like the original Higurashi art, so...
To me...
This is like, peak, you know?
Oh, I was off.
I can't, I'm still too dumb to, like, read the maps, though.
Or, like, remember things, you know?
Yeah, baby.
To remember each placement.
I used to.
I used to be like, okay, and they come from this side, and
then the fairies come from this side, and then they do this.
but it is a lot of toho is kind of not memorizing i mean i
guess you just need to read them i don't know i was never
great at like sight reading for music never great at sight
reading for for rhythm games
i got i got i just died but that's okay because we continue
on Oh, don't do that.
It's okay.
She's not the strongest.
I'll prove it.
She's the dumbiest.
Oh, shoot.
I'm so not locked in, everybody.
It's over.
She looks so cute, though, or Sprite.
I don't know what it is, but I'm a fan of the sound of when
you're, like, hitting them.
It's, like, that rumbly sound.
Something about it's real satisfying to me.
Anybody else?
It's like a...
You know?
That sound.
Something about it just sounds good.
The harms in this are...
The harms in this go crazy in this version.
Sorry, I will just probably say whatever and I'll...
Oh shoot, no!
I will ask you guys questions and I will forget to read.
Feel like I'm learning so much in math.
I'll catch an air conditioner cold.
I don't think it's me being in the flow state.
It's me trying to entertain because I don't want to just
play in silence.
This streamer must perform.
Dance, monkey dance.
There's one like animated something or other about that I
really like with Mei Ling and Sakuya.
And it's like the room cleaning stopped.
And anyone else watch the home
cleaning stop.
Oh shoot, I ran right into that.
My bad.
I think we've got her boards.
Hong Mei Ding.
May theme.
Oh, shoot.
Having infinite lives is pretty nice, though.
Oh, we get a 1-up!
Wow!
One woman formation.
Yeah, Minto Infinity.
So awesome.
Like I said, I really just want to kind of, like, get
through.
If I can do sub...
Hmm...
No, I'm not gonna say anything.
Are we gonna say sub, like, a certain amount lives?
Oh my god!
My finger slipped!
No!
I wasted a bomb!
Sub 50.
I don't know.
Bro, give me something really generous, okay?
Be really generous with me.
Oh my gosh.
Hi Johnny.
Hello baby.
Hello.
Hi baby boy.
You went up.
You went in my lap.
Oh my gosh.
My cat is wanting in my lap.
I think.
Hello.
Hi.
Come into my lap.
Come here.
My cat wants to get in my lap.
Yes you are allowed.
I grant you access.
stop don't bite that he is not oh my goodness he is not a
kitten but he acts like one yeah stop he acts like a kitten
a little bit because oh my god stop stop it let go let go
thank you he uh he he has like very small brain cells going
on in his head everybody at the they were like he is not
very cat like he's um he's like he just kind of bonks his
head all the time and he um is more dog than cat yeah he's
kind of dog like yeah he's a very silly guy you're so silly
okay i'm trying to place my stuff in a way oh sorry i'm
everything's bonking so that i can have him in my lap but
not have to hold him, so I can still play.
Come here.
Hey.
Hey, silly boy.
He silly.
He was very sick as a kitten.
yes, weren't you?
You were so sick as a kitten.
So, he had some surgeries and stuff.
He didn't kind of...
Stop it!
Develop.
Uh...
I guess the same way as other cats.
Alright, let's resume the game.
Don't bite that.
That's the cord to my mic.
Yeah, that's okay.
He's better now.
He's good now.
I can't, I don't know if you guys can hear him.
Here, I'll turn off my, uh...
Can you hear him?
The noise gate?
Oh, it doesn't seem like it.
Never mind.
Okay.
Resume game.
Oh, he's looking at the screen.
Like, hardcore.
No, don't bite my...
Don't lick my hands, please.
Sorry, buddy.
Don't lick my hands.
Don't lick me.
Please.
I'm playing on...
Stop chewing my cable, please.
Stop.
I'm playing on extra hard mode, guys.
Stop fighting!
Stop biting, please!
Lunatic mode plus cat.
This is lunatic mode.
He likes to bite the wires on my headphone.
Heck yeah.
Nope, don't get on my desk, please.
You know what?
I'm just gonna bomb through it.
Maybe I should have waited.
Oh, I should have waited, probably.
It's okay.
Oh, nice.
Hello, Jonathan.
Oh, you are so cute, but you are a little menace, you are.
He's, like, gotten so comfortable with me.
Just in, like, literally within a half hour of him being at
my cafe, he was, like, on top of me.
Are you leaving?
Are you heading out?
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't mean to bomb, but you know what?
It's okay, actually.
just go around these oh man hi johnny everybody say bye to
johnny
wait sorry it's
not your food time yet what time is it anyway you didn't get
out of my chair hey hey
now john johnny show it johnny akiba jonathan akiba jonathan
akiba You need to leave.
Come on.
Okay, I'm going to go feed him real quick.
I'll be right back.
Jonathan, come on.
Come in.
I don't think he's hungry, you guys.
He's not eating his food.
He's just being a booger.
He wants to play.
He doesn't want to do anything else.
He won't let me stream.
Okay.
Alright.
Back to the game.
Hello.
Buddy.
No!
Stop!
Hello.
Yay!
We got the Koakuma!
Oh my gosh, I forgot she had these.
What are you doing?
Ones!
Yeah!
Oh, jeez.
Why am I more locked in than I was before, you know?
The cat only plays with cables when she knows it'll get my
attention.
Johnny might be crafty.
Or he might be stupid.
I had to...
I had to bomb myself out of that one.
Oh!
No!
40 at 10 lives.
Death, death, death.
Ah, ah, gosh.
Ah, what the heck do I thought I had that one?
Okay, we're fine.
Oh my god, it's so bad.
It's so bad.
Doesn't this house have any windows?
And didn't it look smaller from the outside?
One of my favorite themes?
Oh, you there, red-white.
No rough housing in my study.
Oh, gosh, she looks really dumb.
Study, red-white.
These books are worth five years of offerings to your
shrine.
My shrine gets no visitors all year round.
But she's poor.
Well, I guess that's what they're worth.
By the way, can you actually read in such a dark room?
I'm not night blind like you.
Locked, girl, yeah.
Why does everyone keep calling me night blind?
Forget about that.
Are you in charge here?
What do you want with the mistress?
She's spreading too much mist.
It's kind of a problem.
I see that I'm definitely not letting you see her.
Don't get in my way.
Who are you anyway?
That was tough.
That put me in a tough spot.
Oh,
dang it.
Oh, shh.
Okay.
I'm locking in.
I'm getting cozy because of the infinite lies, you know?
Oh.
Nice.
I hate these ones.
I hate them.
Let's add that door.
Ugh.
Oh, no.
No.
I tried to get it, Anna.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I mean, we basically are, like, kind of blind playing all of
these, though, so...
But it's not really how you're supposed to play to her.
I just want to hear the music.
She's washed.
Didn't I say that I was, though?
Infinite lives, my beloved.
Oh my god.
I don't know if you can... I don't think you can reach...
Or... I don't remember if it said you can reach Blonde on
Infinite.
Your first serious run is after much practice, it's true.
There's someone here who likes to mess with space.
A very angry bookworm.
Checking my cat.
Honestly,
we're just kind of playing for funsies, so don't get too
serious about it.
Whoa, oh, I saw it right at the last second.
I should have, I could have bombed, but I didn't.
Oh, oops.
That one was mine.
Why so serious?
Oh my god!
Wait, oh shoot.
Wait, I didn't even get to read it.
I was too busy looking at her.
She's her own mid-boss, isn't she?
Yeah, I forgot.
Oh, shah, shah, shah.
My girl.
Oh my god.
It's not clear, it's not clear.
son oh my gosh guys she's insane just bomb just bomb i mean
who would do that who would who would do that who needs to
bomb through these that'd be that'd be crazy
oh yeah we got a one up i
was i was greedy These dang fairies get so scary.
You're getting the way of my cleaning again.
You probably aren't the lady of the house.
So what is it?
Are you a guest of the mistress?
She probably won't let me pass if I tell her that I came to
defeat her mistress.
You may not pass.
The mistress rarely meets anyone.
house arrest?
Why would you ask that?
She enjoys dark places.
And someone not so dark like you will do.
You're the one spreading this mist all over the place,
right?
It's a nuisance.
What are you trying to do?
Daylight is bothersome.
My mistress prefers it dim.
Well, I don't, so could you stop it already?
Ask the mistress yourself.
Then call her here.
And why would I place the mistress in danger?
Maybe she'll show up if I make a big enough fuss out here.
But even...
But so you won't be able to meet with the mistress.
After all, if necessary, I can stall for time by stopping
time.
Zawarudo!
I probably should have.
But it's fine.
Whoa, so cool.
Oh my gosh, I forgot about this.
Ow, we go!
Oh my god, no!
I saw it at the last second!
Oh shoot.
I'm in trouble.
I'm not in trouble Yeah
Sorry I know I was about to hit it
Oh my god Oh my god oh my god How the hell are you supposed
to read this stuff How did I use to read it?
Brain please Revert I am Once again I'm I am once again 19!
Nice.
Oh my god, wait, I think I walked right into it.
That's so silly.
Guys,
remember when I was like, don't be intimidated by...
Remember when I said don't be intimidated by Toho before?
Holy hell.
What was I thinking?
It always gets worse!
And this isn't even like the hardest game.
if comparatively speaking I'd say this game is quite not
difficult compared to other did I say sub 50 to other Toho
games oh my gosh we saved ourselves maybe by getting that
freaking hell try lunatic no no you're the lunatic for doing
that.
Now in a faith is...
is not bad, yeah.
You be letting me meet her now?
She's strong.
Maybe the mistress can.
Johnny, hold on.
I'm gonna go check on my kit.
Sorry, he's brand new.
He's still getting used to everything, so I'd like to check
on him like a worried mom, you know?
Ah!
Wait,
what was that sound?
What was that sound?
What did I just hear?
Oh, that was my fault.
I at least have to make you waste...
Oh, can you shut up and go...
Oh, okay.
I wasn't even clicking anything.
I wasn't even clicking anything, please!
Oh, dang.
Oh, I was actually getting that.
Nice.
Let's go.
Isn't it about time you showed yourself?
Mistress.
Look how cute she is.
Oh, God.
She looks so dumb.
I knew it.
Humans are useless.
So that maid was human.
That makes you a murderer.
Remilia!
My mistress!
Don't worry, it was only one person, so I'm hardly a serial
killer.
Well, oh, right, you're being a huge nuisance.
How quick you are to accuse.
And I don't even know why.
Whatever, could you just leave?
If this is my castle, is it not?
The only one leaving is you.
I want you to leave this world over the road.
Oh, well, I guess you leave me no choice.
I'm already full, but...
Didn't you hire that maid to protect you?
I can take a sheltered young lady like you down in one blow.
Sakuya is an excellent cleaner.
Thanks to her not a single head litters the floor.
Are you strong?
Who knows?
I don't get to go out.
Often.
Since I'm weak to sunlight.
So you are strong, then.
I know the dialogue is so savage, right?
It's so funny.
Seeing how the moon is so scarlet, I think I'll kill you for
real.
Even though the moon is so scarlet, looks like it's going to
be a fun night.
Looks like it's going to be a long night.
Oh, they're saying it at the same time.
Shoot, already on the first card.
Let's go.
Check out all this grace.
have made that, but I am not quite sure if I did.
Oh, it sounds so good.
Wow, sing it.
Do you guys know I have a cover of this, official?
Oh, it sounds so good.
Hold on, wait.
Hurry up.
Oh, I didn't mean to, sorry, I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, the tiny ones always get me.
I hate these guys.
Don't listen to me, sound to me dying.
Listen to the music.
Oh, it sounds so good.
Oh, my God.
Screw that.
I don't feel like dealing with it.
Let's go.
I tried to bomb.
Oh, well.
Oh, we're good.
Shoot!
Oh my god!
I didn't reach it.
Freaking love bats.
Oh, I saw it coming right at me in the last second.
No!
My sub 50!
Ah, he tried the bomb against me.
Screw you.
You're a beautiful creature.
so stinking cute i can't be mad at you i can't be mad at you
i can't stay mad at you
victory the incident is resolved exercise romellia scarlet
you and your beautiful don maku oh my gosh
oh get either of the bad endings clear the game on normal a
summer day at the unpopular shrine it had yet it had yet to
recover the sun's brilliance so what am i supposed to do now
is beating the culprit the only way to clear the mist why is
it so cold anyway would the mist really disappear once she's
taken down more training was needed the scarlet summer
continued bad ending number one eight for five or fewer
deaths adorable guys you think we almost hit the
For sure.
Yippee!
Turn it back down again.
For Johnny's sake, we must do our part to convince Minto
that wireless devices are bad.
The what?
The sparky spaghetti is every cat's right.
No!
At least my!
Headphones cost $20.
I don't know how to get out of the...
Wait, am I even in it?
I might have clicked out of the game.
Oh.
This part is unskippable.
So, oops.
The Anmaku script.
You mad, man.
Hold control.
me
mintum mint mint plus um
heck no heck no do you want to save this who am I kidding I
feel like I could maybe get the patchouli
I don't know Who knows Much more Much more practice is
necessary It's already saved to YouTube No No I don't think
I don't think extras unlocked you guys Yeah see Or Yeah I
cannot do To Flaan For that minute of lock-in it was really
cool thanks I have my mom oh no no not challenge modes the
other modes I have my I have my moments honestly I feel um I
feel I still feel good
like considering how actually long it's been since I last
played this you know I don't feel I don't it could be worse
could be way worse probably I think everybody should try
this it's not so expensive and it's it's quite fun when you
really hit the flow state it's kind of relaxing sometimes I
would just play like in between you know in between stuff
did I Did I hit that?
Did I get her?
I don't.
I actually wasn't paying attention.
Oh, I was thinking of playing other Marisa, but...
Oh, oops.
I ran right into that.
This might not be the run, guys.
Never thought of Toha as a flow state activity, but it makes
sense.
Can't look at chat.
I can't...
That's why I've been harsh.
Well, kind of why I'm dying.
Other is just me being bad.
Other part is game hard.
Game hard guys, game hard.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh wow!
You should see some of the spell cards that happen.
It gets... Oh hello Johnny.
Hello.
You okay?
Where'd you go?
You alright?
Yeah, yeah, what are you saying?
Mr. I think he, I think we'll stop soon.
Sorry if it's a shorter stream today.
He is still getting used to the place.
And so I've been trying to like stay with him as much as
possible.
But obviously, I'm really happy that I could play this on
day of release because Originally, I had it planned for day
of release and then Barry asked if I wanted to play Toho.
Not Toho, but to play Halo.
And I was like, oh, of course.
Yeah, but she asked for Wednesday.
And I was like, but then obviously her stuff came up.
And I was like, all good.
I'll play Toho.
No.
Oh my gosh, it feels really weird playing it again though.
Ah!
Are you okay?
I pick you up and I put you in my lap.
Don't... He keeps falling.
He's extremely clingy, you guys.
Like, so clingy.
You okay?
You alright?
You're okay.
You're alright.
Yep, you're okay.
You're fine.
You're so clingy and silly.
You're so silly, you know that?
You're such a silly little guy.
Can you guys hear him?
His prayers are very loud.
and he's got a big sniffer he's got big sniffs you could
hear the boy okay i'm gonna play now and you're gonna leave
sure sniffer sniffer sniffer oh my finger slipped
yeah If you hear stuff, it's him.
I don't know what he's doing.
That's another thing that makes me anxious is I don't know
his personality.
I know a little bit, but not enough to where, like, I
don't...
I'm like, can I...
He's not so young, that's the thing.
But I'm like, can I leave you alone?
He's a couple years old!
What are you doing?
Bing Bong mentioned?
Of course.
I don't have no idea if it's safe from...
Oops.
From nibbling.
Baka!
Baka baka!
Nice, nice.
Baka, baka.
Baka, baka, baka.
I don't think, though.
I'll make it to Patchouli.
Maybe another time.
I'll see my girl.
I had a feeling I wouldn't make that Congrats on the kitty
Thank you He's been very good all things considered He's
been very good He's a good guy He's a cute little baby But
Oops Um He's so cute But he's a little sinker.
And
this morning I woke up to I was out of bed like an hour
earlier than usual because I woke up to his paws on my neck
and on my face.
I was like, okay.
That's how we're doing things now.
Oh, and he's, yeah, he smelled, his breath smells so bad.
Really Stinky.
Really, really stinky.
Oh, shoot.
No!
Sounds nice and clingy.
He is.
Very clingy.
Classic Johnny.
I know.
It's really just funny to be like, Johnny!
Johnny Akibo!
And when he's in real trouble, I say Jonathan Akihara.
I'm not awesome.
Stinky?
What are we talking about?
Ay,
ay, ay, ay.
Cat reflects the streamer.
I disagree.
Oh.
Stop.
I need to lock in, guys.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
I hope you guys have enjoyed a new Toho so far, though.
It's pretty fun.
I mean, it's just Toho, which is fun.
Which is pretty dang burn.
And it is like history, you know?
Ah!
Wait, did I...
I did die, but I got a 1-up at the same time.
That was crazy.
Yo, that was crazy.
Oh, that's true.
I think I was gonna get hit there.
Appreciate you for playing this live.
Toho could use more love.
I mean, it's like...
Had its lull in years.
But you know what's...
What has...
The resurgence?
Have been young children in Japan.
Oh, dang it.
That's not bad.
Children in Japan have been like obsessed with Toho again.
Which is so fun.
And I know that I've been sponsored by Toho.
lost word, but you know, that always contributes to games
like that, contribute.
Maybe the kids will be alright.
Grab it.
Oh shoot, I didn't even see where that was at.
That's my bud.
Wow.
It like crossed over further than I thought it was going to.
Thank you for the super chat!
I'm sorry, I can't read it right now.
I'm sorry.
Screw it.
Bane of my existence.
Give it to me.
Screw you.
Ah, Zomori, thank you so much for the vibe, Captain.
I'm so sorry, Mistress, she says.
You got through somehow.
I don't think we'll be making it to Patchouli.
That's okay.
Oh my god, I ran right into him!
I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid, you guys.
Thanks.
Yeah, this is a...
I'm an expert at Toho, trust.
This is actually a secret mode called, uh...
It says normal, but it's actually like...
Normal.
It's actually like...
It's a secret normal level.
It's not actually normal.
Screw these dang...
I forget about these books every time.
oh my god there's so many of them a little koakuma that
was close yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah big boy got me a big ball
koakuma koakuma koakuma she's just a tiny little demon
she's just a daemon you you suck oh my gosh I was trapped in
there you assholes you you heck
heck oh I'm heckin screwed oh my gosh sorry I have to bomb
twice because I'm bad at the game bomb bomb Bomb!
It's okay, I'm gonna die anyway.
Ah, bomb your way to see Patchy!
I was so close to seeing her!
That part's brutal.
Oh man.
Ugh.
Alright, let's do one last.
One last.
On lunatic.
Difficulty for those who are a bit strange.
We'll do...
We'll do Master Spark.
Or...
Come on, check on me, son!
They're already shooting at me.
I feel so fast now.
Oh my god.
Holy hell!
We're not even...
Oh my god!
Actually, I feel like this is the Marisa I used to play.
Maybe I'm crazy.
Am I gonna get her?
Yeah!
No?
Did I?
I don't think I did actually.
Oh shoot!
Oh, I died at the same time though.
Holy hell.
Stop.
Room cleaning, stop.
Nice weaving, thank you.
Holy cow.
I wonder how many lives it would take to get through.
Get through this.
I already feel like I'm getting more used to it, you know
what I mean?
Which, you may not tell, but I honestly do feel like it a
little bit.
Oh, oops, I ran right into that.
Yeah, like I said, you may not be able to.
These games, you know, like I said, they are a daunting
bunch.
A daunting bit.
But, you know, you can already see how...
Wow!
You can already see like...
How...
Just even like a couple, like an hour or something to
practice can...
Yeah.
Snowy, thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you so much!
Wow!
I'm a lunatic player.
I'm a luni.
I hate the screen though.
It's so hard to see.
What the heck?
Oh!
She's kind of a mad woman.
I am.
Oh.
Whoa, my gosh.
Don't do that.
Oh.
This is out now?
Out today, actually.
Out today.
Big fairy.
Small fairy, big heart.
Check that out.
Oh, yeah.
I feel like, though, playing Toho also always feels like...
Like, uh, how do you say?
Feels like...
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just hoping for the best.
Every time I play, I'm like, am I gonna...
You know, obviously I can do my best to dodge, but...
Oh, shoot.
Dang it, I went back to that.
You just go with the flow.
Truly.
Oh.
So my eyes can't see.
It is so...
it's so blue
I don't even know oh dang it I went right into that I was
trying to find her
hail storm
oh shoot it is like there's no way you can play these games
in one try though like it's you have to learn the like how
was I supposed to know those were gonna start shooting at me
Oh, oops.
I saw her like her chat.
Maybe I'm meant for this game, though.
Look how well I'm doing, guys.
I'm a Toho player.
It's in my DNA.
Gotta download the spell cards into your HUD, truly.
Wait, I didn't think I would get this far, though.
I didn't think I would get this far.
I thought I would die in like two seconds.
Stop sending me...
Stop...
I mean, I will die eventually in like two seconds, but...
Let's check that graze out.
I think I actually could have made that, but I was too
scared.
Do you ever just bomb out of like...
Necessity?
Wait, how am I doing this?
That wouldn't.
That one was not gonna happen.
Stop sending little knives at me, please.
Please.
Please scare me.
Oh, I have no more bombs.
It's over.
Hold on, my Ling.
Oh, dang it.
I was not paying attention.
How?
I don't know how, though.
I'm, like, able to...
Get this part.
Lunatic!
I don't know, you guys!
That might be crazy!
Oh.
It's because it's for crazy people.
Obviously.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, here it comes.
Everybody, it's over.
It's over now.
It's over.
It's so...
Okay, I got...
I ran into the ferry.
It's so over.
Okay.
Everything's so fast.
Oh my god.
Stop it.
You came right at me.
It's so over.
We lost every health that we had.
It's okay.
It's so over.
It's so over?
It's not over until she steals the precious thing.
Wrong game!
Next game!
Oh.
It's so over?
Oh, it's so over.
I'm not just saying that.
I'm not just trying to be like, hee hee guys.
Oh, shah.
Honestly, could have been worse.
Could have been much worse.
She must reach the library.
No!
Min, um, finishes
that was pretty good
yeah that could have been much worse but now look at this I
can practice on every stage and that's the best part happy
turtle day thanks for the nostalgia I'm still getting used
to patchy having no stripes it's weird it's weird wait Oh,
wow.
Wait.
I can go by spell card.
Oh, I can go by the captured ones.
Interesting.
Wait, what?
It's so...
Look at it.
She's got no stripes on.
Why'd they make her naked?
I thought I was in practice.
I guess I'm in like...
Hi.
How did I get this before?
Hold on, hold on, we can do this.
This is not an excuse to listen to her theme over and over
again.
Oh, dang it.
Ah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, give up.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, it's such a banger.
Oh, it's so good.
I think my chair is breaking.
It's a good thing I ordered a new one recently.
I was thinking recently, I was like, if people knew how I
streamed my streaming setup, you guys might go insane.
Didn't expect to see the old model.
Hi!
Long time no see.
Oh, I'm done.
Hello, he went in my lap.
You laying down.
Oh, there we go.
Let me get this, please.
Stop it.
He's so sweet.
He's so cute.
Johnny, I love him.
Come here.
He loves in my lap.
Come in my lap.
Oh, well, thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
No, thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you, another 50.
Holy cow.
Oh, my God.
My cat is...
Oh, he's on my shoulders.
Thank you, guys.
So much for Toho.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Yes.
Do you have anything you'd like to say?
This is your...
This is your debut on stream.
Anything you'd like to say.
Yeah.
I'll let him speak.
Can you hear him?
One second.
Oh, sorry.
Say, say something.
Johnny debut.
Can you hear him?
Karin.
Very slightly, here I'll turn up my mic.
Hello.
Oh, he's drooling on me.
Oh, he's gross.
Oh, he's so nasty.
Oh, gross.
Oh, he smells bad.
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Ew.
Ew, it smells so bad.
Johnny, Johnny, do you want, where do you want to go?
You want to go where?
Mr. Akiba.
No, don't, don't do that.
I accidentally sent in the group chat chat a very funny um
message because it was just johnny walking on my keyboard
i've never had a cat like this kind of you know hey hey stop
it stop and he's not even a kitten like he's a couple years
old oh all right thank you johnny thank you you can lay
right there you can lay right there yeah
Walking on keyboards is a classic cat move.
Yeah, but I've never had a cat that would do that before.
Hey, dear boy.
Oh, stop.
Stop chewing on that, please.
Stop it.
Ew.
Oh, it's wet.
Oh.
You're so gross.
All right.
I'll go, I'll go, I'll go try to get him to eat again.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for Toho.
This was fun.
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
Wow.
Darko, thank you so much for the super, for the ugly super.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
We were much closer to five deaths than Infinite on
challenge.
That's very true.
Congrats on new kitty.
he sounds like the silliest little guy he is and there were
akasupas earlier i'm so sorry that i missed them though i
should have turned off uh i should have turned off super
chats for this stream because i because i wasn't able to
read them at all but i really really appreciate it thank you
guys so much i didn't even think about it to be honest oh i
will for next stream though enjoyed seeing little old me
feeling a little bit of nostalgia together with all of this
so um yeah thank you guys thank you so much ozumi wait
because of this because of this we'll do something that i
very rarely do but i very rarely do uh
I've pricked the wrong one, but that's okay.
Everybody's already, you guys already know.
If
there's something strange,
bed let me tell you some if there's something weird sleeping
in your bed oh let me tell you something busting makes me
feel good
busting busting busting busting bust Bustin, Bustin, Bustin,
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin,
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin,
Bustin Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin,
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin, Bustin Yeah!
Busting, busting, busting, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny, Johnny,
Johnny, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting, busting, busting, makes me...
Meow good!
Oh, he's back up here again.
Hello!
Feel good.
Freaky ghost maid.
Freaky ghost cat.
Freaky man baby.
Ow!
Ow if you're all alone.
Let me sleep in your bed.
Ew.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
feel good.
Phew!
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
I'm drawn here drooling all over me again.
Nasty and invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stinky, stinky, stinky, stinky, stinky.
Ew, you are so gross right now.
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Oh my gosh.
Feel good.
Shady, not big like you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Busting, boosting, boosting, boosting.
Love him when winter falls.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting.
Busting, busting.
Makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Busting, busting, busting, busting.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting Makes me feel
good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good Yeah, yeah,
yeah Busting, busting, busting Thank you, everybody!
Otsumito!
Have a good time zone wherever you are!
And I will see you when I see you next!
Otsumito!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!